what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we're gonna watch a bad
batch episode 12. Michael are you
excited I'm so excited multihouse.io we
had syllabus leave alive we had clones
yeah
Commandos yes hey subscribe subscribe
like subscribe and comment if you want
to have great Star Wars discussions guys
let's uh watch the show now we're gonna
have the best time I'm so excited this
is Greg's favorite television
[Music]
all right
The Outpost
like where you deliver mail like where
the Clone Rebellion is based
please
give it to me Hondo is hiring then
oh I like Whistler oh my God good tone
that's you know when you're in a good
tone
across
finally I thought they couldn't renew
his contract or something yeah I'm
lieutenant
your commanding officer for this Mission
we're heading to the Imperial Depot on
Barton 4 high value cargo store there
has been targeted by local insurgents
where to secure it until it's
transferred weeks yummy I hate his face
so much
oh fantastic more clones
problem sir I don't like used equipment
I can't you say that about lovers but
what did you do
yeah I don't think we heard each other
no you were you were going one way
[Music]
that's LA right now okay I'm telling me
man yeah
[Music]
now illum's being turned into Starkiller
base come on no no no no no I'm pretty
sure we're getting kyber crystals now
you got to get better at your game man
you got this [__]
dumb Imperials so much I hope he just
goes AWOL man they're really like let's
make our last five episodes look
freaking awesome
what the mortise bird no I thought I
think it is a thousand percent trust me
so now we're stepping into the thing
[Laughter]
where is your supervisor you must be our
reinforcements we expected you 36
rotations ago oh God Kurt Russell we
work on the Empire's scheduled Trooper
not yours it's Commander where are the
rest of your men dad your feelings will
be dealt with later
you uh know the lieutenant well
for about two hours two hours too long I
bet
oh my God he's gonna bond with
this is actually really helpful for
Crosshair yeah
the name's mayday
wait a second Crosshair
welcome to MayDay The Outpost
nope don't remember mayday I'll give you
a layer of the land
we are in the thing yeah we're told
oh you have no idea wanted that myself
every day you don't know apparently it's
above a Clone Trooper's pay grade can I
actually be kyber you might be right
don't go far
unless what's in the ice kills you first
either way it'll make them happy
oh
cut them off I do feel this season
needed more Crosser yeah it's gripping
when he's on screwed it really is
[Applause]
feels like a real Soldier
you know he fought in Stalingrad oh cool
yeah
I love the setting here
no he's got a Crosshair though
[Music]
if it is kyber crystals I don't think it
is that might be who knows
be adventurous Greg I have theories it
could be kyber crystals it could be a
Jedi and sabotaging them trying to stop
the Empire from getting their hands on
the crystals that will be used to fuel
the Death Star
[Music]
foreign
must have fled on foot into the mountain
pass
oh this is neat oh that's how they
should have passed all defenses
I'm loving the vibe of this one a lot
we don't have the Manpower or gear for a
mission beyond the perimeter especially
just to recover a few crates up to you
to determine what is of value to the
Empire then I need all your men for this
Mission yeah [__] Outpost vulnerable
to another attack this task Falls to you
too and you two alone recover the cargo
is that clear how does the Empire
attract such pompous [__] they
recruit from all the Ivy League schools
yeah it's like what happened you guys
weren't like pompous [__] before the
Empire now it's like nothing but
it's just like one thing canonically
that like
they're so bad at what they do why would
you ever replace the Clones who are just
so good at what they do
well it is
n't carrying dead weight
not to die on your watch
this is a fun little pairing
I know I hope they fall in love Go
Disney maybe one day
it's been a rock it's okay
what were you saying about dead weights
[Laughter]
is I don't feel like carrying your body
back to the Outpost I guess I'll give it
a shot
I like him I know I like mayday's
attitude a lot
I wish I had the proper equipment for
this
the empires ignored all my requests
I guess all clones have had to since the
war
nail that into the snow it's ice don't
pick up your food [__] wait until I tell
you then lift it
real slow like
all the way around the bend if I don't
hear a boom then I'll know it worked
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then they kill off Crosshair walk
away
then he steps on us
you guys gonna have to cuddle up keep
corn keep warm
I hope Crosshair does not kill Mayday I
like mayday's attitude a lot oh
Splinter's Cell nice
I love these
multiple episodes of Crosshair getting
to just team up and go ham yeah with
another Clone Commander question
everything he's doing
thank you
perfect shot damn
you guys are a great team yeah right
I love it they're the snow people
okay
[Music]
my favorite video game trick
good job you guys can recover the cargo
now that's so good
you guys must be freezing I can hear
them going Burr if you listen really
close
take off your helmet in this weather
your ears would be so cold yeah
we've been risking Our Lives to recover
equipment we could have been wearing
this whole time oh that is cold oh man
Avalanche
oh shoot it Crosshair
that'll stop it
[Music]
wow
oh no
better just helped save crosshair's life
and just like that crosshair's heart
grew three sizes
that you're wishing you had your helmet
on right about now huh
is he gonna try to save him definitely
yeah his death might be the linchpin
that Sparks the rebellion and crosshairs
heart
oh man if he dies he's gonna kill the
other Imperial officer
oh no no don't kill Mayday I love this
guy
all right I won't make it
[Laughter]
oh [__]
oh my God Crosser don't you tell him in
my heart again man oh man
his bald head must be freezing freezing
yeah
[Music]
oh the cheeks and the ears
you feel it
this is great oh damn yeah no I love
this one
[Music]
all those elements man versus nature
or they are elements yeah
and they're gonna come back to a rude
thankless bureaucrat
[Music]
they are doing the cuddle up
remind me they do they don't they all
have a bit of extra enhanced strength uh
they all have their own kind of unique
yeah yeah but due to them but generally
speaking Yeah
oh
follow me
this [__] yeah it was David Bowie
looking [__]
step aside step aside dude I hope you
get shot right now
with those crates oh
this is it for Crosshair yeah about time
you two returned
it's a medical attention yeah
I see you didn't retrieve the crates
which means you failed
this guy is such help him that would be
a waste of the Empire's resources he'll
die
he served his purpose as a soldier of
the empire
oh
chose the wrong words you didn't hear me
he
he is expendable
as are you oh and if you speak to me
again with such disrespect I'll see to
it you meet a similar fate Club
poor guy man he needed it yeah
[Music]
[__] he's gonna do it yes
I think you sent all those workers back
yeah right yeah
never mind
oh [__] is he gonna go all Rambo on them
right now he can't he's too he's way too
[Music]
yes
damn this is like some Film Festival
[__] that we're watching right now you
know hello ct9904
or do you prefer Crosshair
uh
what's the objective here related to
Omega who are you remain calm
cooperate
and you might survive
spooky she kind of sounds a little like
Omega she does doesn't she
I thought that the last episode that'd
be kind of an interesting uh
like she's kind of derived from her DNA
Django or a combination of the two yeah
or maybe they just had a kid
that would be a lot easier
wow uh
man that was great
um
do you remember last episode when we
talked what happened last episode
well last episode we talked about my
theory that you rudely laughed off that
Crosshair will be the one to save Omega
when Omega is inevitably captured by
these people
um oh yeah did it just so happened that
his entire motivation is so simple
location
now it sounds so stupid still it sounds
so worse oh and there's no way no they
didn't totally change his moral compass
I don't see it put him in space uh
impossible yeah and then they're gonna
write it you're reaching right away
together on the Zillow Beast mark my
quest with baby girl guinto
oh that was great no you're right I
think that's gonna happen yeah
um I really hope they don't finish that
or
they
I really don't want us to have the
conclusion of Omega being safe at the
end of the season
um I feel like the stakes deserve to be
higher the interesting Mike
it's pointed towards your mouth a little
more yeah how's that yeah it's better
than facing your the bottom of your chin
whatever I have a beautiful chin
anyway uh yeah no I thought I thought it
was really fun to have I mean this like
Beautiful War Story like yeah these two
old veteran comrades
um and then just to be treated like that
immediately Upon returning
um
it just it was so well done and I think
you know when Crosshair is talking to
mayday it's not just May Day right like
it's the
the collective like Mayday just
represents the collective clone
experience
um well it's also encompassing the
events that he had encountering Cody
yeah you know yeah where it's the
continuation of well you know Cody went
AWOL
this guy stayed behind and continued to
do his job and this is what happens yeah
um I mean this is the most overt
exposure I think he's maybe not the he's
seen some bad treatment of the Clones
but this is at least from what we've
seen
of seeing Crosshair scene [__] yeah this
is the worst like they they're like yeah
they're good nope equipment for the new
guys you guys suffer insults or lives
don't matter this guy just talks that
this guy is literally like prejudiced
against clones he treats them like they
are not human whatsoever which is which
is interesting because when they first
introduced the bad batch I mean even the
first like I think it's season two the
Clone Wars when we first hear the phrase
bad batch uh really and that's when yeah
it's it's in reference to uh when fives
Echo and and Company are in training and
trying to get this is in season two yeah
season two it's really early on now it's
not the bad batch as a group as much as
other clones talking about like oh yeah
you don't want to be like one of the bad
backs okay uh of course 99 being like
the official uh yeah exactly
um we didn't even
entertain the idea that they could be
epic and awesome like this bad batch but
um but I feel like there is within the
bad batch I mean even they call them the
regs yeah regulars like
um I think it it it's been fun to watch
that perception of their fellow clones
change like sure where they thought they
were better than I think in some ways
because they were different and because
also because they were looked at as less
than by I think a lot of the Clones and
now they're all in the same boat
um I'm on a boat um yeah uh it's going
fast uh and if you don't do something
about it yeah might get decommissioned
by the Empire so
um yeah I mean they're setting up I mean
we have what two episodes left
uh yes I think so yeah yeah I mean it's
um
that got a lot to accomplish I don't
think we're seeing the Clone Rebellion
uh I don't think so
last time I was like yeah I wonder how
they're going to wrap this up neatly was
during the final season of Game of
Thrones and well we all know how that
turned out yeah I think that this
particular episode is uh one of my
favorites of the bad batch in total yeah
um again this show proves that as much
as I like last episodes a little beast
and and surprisingly it the main
characters were the bad badges
this season continues to prove that yeah
when it's not the bad match you're the
main characters it is I mean techno
Crosshair was introduced as as a member
of the bad batch so it still is a bad
batch focus and it is interesting seeing
his experience this
the this constant conflict this guy is
in because he's had a very main
objective of good soldiers follow orders
you know and even that gets echoed back
to him ah Echo and with this character
Mayday I really enjoyed his personality
and presence I kind of fell in love with
that character right away because as
much as he sounds like every other clone
we've heard he he has to be Bradley
Baker yeah he has this
um it's not exactly full this is
sarcastic it's a bit of a sarcastic
nature to him
um a bit apathetic but you could just
tell he's just so dreary and worn out
and I loved this kind of
cynical approach to life that he's happy
you can tell he still cares like he's
just he's got that kind he's just got
all these interesting complexities that
he and he's like such a physical
demonstration of it all around and I
loved seeing them interact and of course
the way they do the visual language with
animation with cross hair I thought this
was the best looking bad batch episode
because of the I mean I love I'm a
sucker for
um ice no Landscapes and the atmosphere
and because it's always beautiful but
harsh you know like you got that that
two opposing uh elements to deal with or
the the way you take that in right and
when you have characters on a lot of
times when we're saying like oh this
looks gorgeous and beautiful we're
usually talking about like setting
establishments Landscapes whatever but
this I thought they really brought the
character animation and expression to
life and that's what I was saying like
that film festival comic because I was
like this was very artistic it reminded
me a lot of like the the last three
episodes yeah exactly where there's just
this cinematic bump up yeah
um and you know it it really even the
colors feel like a little richer and a
little deeper which I'm sure is
exacerbated because of of the snow
um because they don't go into the
crosshairs backstory in this episode so
I weirdly felt like this could have been
some like short film that would they
would just release you know yeah that's
true like you need no contact you don't
uh just know where it takes what it
takes place yeah but other than that you
don't need a no crosshairs backstory or
anything no it's it and it reminded me
of I mean some of my favorite episodes
of The Clone Wars are just following the
relationship between clones and them
going out learning I mean that's how we
we learn to love fives and Echo and this
guy like
um and this episode kind of felt like
the two are like watching the the bond
that comes from the trauma of War yeah
only without the at least we can be
proud about what we did and it was for a
greater cause now you have these
soldiers that like everything that they
do comes with just resentment and a
sense of like I mean it reminds me a lot
of and I'm sure this is what they're
going for but like in the Vietnam War
when veterans would get home and like be
spat on at the exact part like uh and
and look down upon by a bunch of these
snooty you know that's why Rambo kill
everyone in that town yeah I mean or one
person
people often think he went on a massacre
but yeah he actually did not he passed
out he went nap time uh but yeah he
massacred everyone on the face uh what
do you think reject Nation about Greg
imagining in his mind of mass
slaughtering some people thought and
that was just kind of the Mis memories
that people
people have that with Rambo or they
think he murdered the whole town yeah of
course he did
um no I only murdered a couple people I
don't think he murdered anyone I don't
remember now yeah Rambo is actually a
Quaker it's a non-violent yeah he's a
pacifist
he's brilliant misunderstood yeah uh
yeah I I think and also they just they
had characters that I thought
represented the World building to such a
strong definition like whoever this dick
wad was uh the the lieutenant he was
such a pompous [__] and I I loved it
I loved that just you got these three
people yeah and they are the
representation of where we are in the
state of this world and I think for a
follow-up to clone wars this is one of
the better episodes of doing it because
you know when you think about the Clones
they went through they were they were
such a beloved characters and then you
watch the tragedy unfold and it's like
oh they got brainwashed and they killed
the Jedi look at them they're bad
and then you see that damn they they
were just like abused you know they were
straight up they were no different than
droids in the mind they were treated
that way yeah when they are much more
like that they're human human well
they are human yeah I mean it's argue
with you man yeah if there's a clone of
you made would you consider that clone
human or does it have to be the birth of
God do you consider me human in some
ways
can I am I allowed to disagree with you
on something yeah or contractually I
don't think we've had that yet
um Rambo death no no that was not an art
like I
personally am really sick of the
Imperial like standard character like
something I really appreciated about
Clone Wars is that when we met what are
you disagree with me oh I'm disagreeing
with I thought like this character was
no different than every single other oh
definitely officer yeah and and I'm I'm
getting to the point where like
I think we need to see some of the
redeemed like like you have like your
Lauren
um you know who's uh are of course in A
New Hope and then was the the narrator
for yeah like I want to see characters
that have a little bit more depth to
them and that can can still achieve that
same ends where they're they're not
respectful to clones but it's not just
like this random bigotry there's like a
more of a reason for it like well how
good of a soldier could you have been if
you turned on your generals like how can
I trust you not to do that to me oh dude
I like I completely agree with you I
know we're fighting it we're trying to
fight right I agree I agree with you I I
just think that the The Stereotype of
this guy was fitting for this episode no
yeah of course that's what I think I
think the problem is from bad batch to
Rebels to literally all pieces yeah it's
so I mean like and then you just
continue it with like clocks and half
the time yeah half the time they are and
they are just like a hawks where you're
like you're obviously like trying to
present bde but you are not yeah
I feel like they did that with the CIS
where they broke that a little bit or
like when we started to meet like the
other side it was like oh look at these
interesting characters that have like
Dimensions to them and
um you know uh well Greg all in all I'm
so excited for the last two episodes
um are they a two-parter
I don't know oh yeah yeah yeah
um they are because they're like
mandalorians airing we gotta just wrap
it up
I'm telling you final episode
predictions or final two episodes we're
gonna see grogu we're gonna see Hondo
we're definitely gonna spend most of it
with Sid
hahaha
there will be Nerf nuggets there will
not be Riot racing we will figure out
who's in the back to tank in Jedi
Survivor
um do you think
thrawn thrawn thrawn fee
thrawn is fee and Benny and Benny and
the Jets will come back with their
explosions I know I know Benny with
their explosives and they're gonna blow
a hole in the Clone station and save
baby Yoda and that's what's gonna happen
his name grogu is grogu
the child
anyway what do you think is gonna happen
uh I think it's gonna have uh 90 good
qualities and then maybe one percent of
I wish they did this yeah um but hey man
to me this was like a as this might have
been
this might have been my favorite bad
batch episode weirdly enough nice
I feel like you've said that four times
already uh but I guess I can change
people can change this is one of my
favorites I like I so far my favorites
of the Season undoubtedly Cody are the
two with the crosshairs they are of this
season those two are my favorites I
still really liked Riot racing
I got way too much crap that was weird
that was really fun it was a really fun
episode
um that's my favorite one of my favorite
tech episodes ever but in terms of like
I I think these are two wonderfully
isolated episodes one final question
is there anything Sid can do in the last
two episodes to redeem herself to you
other than die
nope that's all I had
yeah I like are they gonna is Sid gonna
be the one to show up at the end of the
day and get them off the planet it would
be funny probably if they if the if the
Empire's hunting them again because they
want to know where that ship is yeah
they hunt them they kill Sid's bar hide
out and they kill Sid and then they find
out that Sid left all her Fortune to the
batch
oh interesting yeah no that's not gonna
happen no no she was probably set it to
have her Fortune be set inflamed not
really even anyway they really set up
the fee character to do nothing huh
yeah it's bad batch that's the show yeah
that's what they do
uh but what if it's like a Multiverse
where there's a branch timeline where
fee please okay we're not doing this
anyway uh thank you guys for watching
I'm Michael Tessler I'm Greg Alba and
this is the real
X
[Music]